oh
what are they doing you might use them
to help clear a trench but the main
weapon you'd use would be grenades I'm
Alexander Watson I'm professor of
history at goldsmiths University of
London I'm an expert on the first world
war I've written three books and today
we're going to be looking at battle
scenes in first world war movies to
judge how real they are
[Music]
the Germans have really made a lot of
effort on their trenches they've brought
their heavy Weaponry to defend the
trenches but they've forgotten to put
any barbed wire down at all in no man's
land you would have had loads and loads
of barbed wire on it I mean that's the
key emission and it's a huge ambition of
course they've done that because they
want her running towards them
by 1918 the German Army wasn't simply
composed of Riflemen in 1918 if the
German Army had been confronted by an
invincible female superhero and they
were shooting at her with bullets and
that didn't work then they can go to a
light machine gun an MGR 815 or they've
got they've got a Miniver a light mortar
7.58 centimeter water that they can that
they can shoot at her so full credit to
Wonder Woman for that
these kind of shafts of light that are
being fired a trace of bullets or
incendiary bullets and there were traces
used in the first world war but they
were mainly used for anti-aircraft work
uh and and by aircraft as well they
weren't used by Frontline machine guns
they would expose your position which
you really didn't want to do because you
bring down artillery and water onto you
and the second reason it would actually
be a war crime using incendiary bullets
against enemy troops was a war crime by
the standards of uh of 1914 to 18. so it
wasn't done
there's another error there you've got a
church in the background and that would
be the first thing to be knocked down by
Heavy Artillery because uh because it
would be a great observation post you
just didn't have high Towers directly
behind the lines three out of ten
one thing that I do appreciate about
this scene is that you do actually have
an officer attempting to lead the men
and keep some sort of control and tell
them where they're going and direct them
that's often forgotten
thank you
okay so this is all wrong I mean firstly
who brings a warning going into no man's
land when you're on an attack you know
they did use warning gongs to signal
that there was a gas attack but in the
trenches gas was used famously in the
first world war it's used from 1915 they
started with chlorine the Germans
introduced phosgene which was more
lethal it's it's pretty light slightly
yellowish so it wasn't that easy to
detect either but gas was an offensive
weapon and that's because both chlorine
and phosgene are heavier than air so if
you're trying to take
trench then if you plaster it with
phosphine or chlorine that gas is going
to sink down into the trench and then
down into the dugouts as well very very
dangerous for defending troops against
attacking troops in the open though you
wouldn't use gas these troops are above
ground Not underneath but the gas sinks
down and your own defending troops are
of course below the ground in trenches
and Dugout so you're actually more
likely to risk them rather than hurt the
attacking troops phosgene for example it
was Lethal but it took a few hours for
soldiers to get really really ill if
you're being attacked by enemy soldiers
really you want an immediate impact
before they get to your trench so as a
result you use shrapnel this isn't a
plausible scenario that we're watching
the scene is implausible but we do get a
really nice look at uh British pH helmet
which was a mid-war gas mask
unfortunately he's wearing it wrongly
you need a an airtight seal for this to
work effectively and the way that they
did that was they stuffed the bottom of
the Mask down their collars
um and he hasn't done that so he's going
to be in trouble in a couple of hours
time this is really a three because they
could at least get the gas mask fitting
right you know
feel the power of these 1918 Central man
French tanks and on top of that I love
how they have them looming through the
smoke they're actually very vulnerable
to artillery fire and so what the french
did was they would put down a smoke
barrage smoke shells in front of the
tanks to obscure them and then they
would come out tour the enemy trenches
and that's really really well
represented
all right
so there's problems as well with how the
germs are behaving here the trench that
they're defending is actually a frenched
French and these French tanks are
counter-attacking and the about trenches
they were built to defend one way so
you'd have the fire step opposite the
enemy facing the enemy you'd have the
machine gun emplacements facing the
enemy as well but in this trench
miraculously all of the fire steps of
defenses suddenly seem to be facing if
you like the wrong way towards towards
the French counter-attackers and it
wouldn't have happened in 1918 if you
saw tanks coming towards you as a German
soldier the first thing you do is you
get your flare gun and you shoot a flare
a signal flare out over to alert the
artillery behind you to bring down a
covering bombardment that's your best
chance of survival the best chance to
hold a trench and there's nothing of
that here by 1918 the Germans had a
number of nasty tricks up their sleeves
in order to fight tanks they've got
lights mortars they're called Min velve
which can be turned horizontal to fire
directly at a tank they've even got
specialized anti-tanker weapons they've
got anti-tank rifles great big huge
rifles which would give this 13
millimeter shot out and which could
penetrate a tank's armor
but these guys are just being presented
as a pretty helpless rifle men
why would you stop and shoot these these
French tanks they've got 75 millimeter
cannon on them they're intended to take
out strong points and to take out
artillery which could be threatening the
tank there's absolutely no reason simply
to shoot straight in front of them at
this trench there's nothing really to be
gained by this is a 23 ton tank and it's
got a 94 horsepower engine in it that's
a smaller engine than your average
modern estate car yeah and that's
pulling this huge huge weight and if you
stop you might get stuck the thing about
war in 1918 is that you keep moving all
the time you keep moving or you're
killed
so this tank appears to be entering the
trench Network
the tank is that far down it's very
unlikely especially with these ones
which were very front heavy because of
that big 75 millimeter gun it's very
unlikely to get out again
okay now this is plausible if the tanks
were separated from their infantry then
German Defenders were able to knock them
out now what these guys are doing is
they haven't got any weapon which can
penetrate the armor of the track tank so
they're going for what's called a
Mobility kill they're blowing off the
tracks using a hand grenade which will
stop it and then they're able to put a
uh a hand grenade into one of the uh one
of the firing ports and blew the crude
Smithereens inside her that is how
German infantry combated tanks in 1918
it was one of the methods
what are they doing the French have come
in they've got flamethrowers
flamethrowers were used they were used
from 1959 onwards the Germans introduced
them the French have their own mobile
flamethrowers as well they didn't carry
a huge amount of liquid that's one thing
and they weren't used in this way either
you might use them to help clear a
trench but the main weapon you'd use
would be grenades but the bigger issue
is you wouldn't have them in the first
wave like this what these French guys
are doing is they are creating an
impenetrable wall of fire through which
no French troops can go
meanwhile the Germans who are retreating
are gonna get away they're gonna
re-entrench and they're going to shoot
everybody down
the chaos and the fair there's a
visceral sense here I mean I think that
is pretty realistic but this scene
couldn't have happened in October 1918
and that's actually misleading people
about the end of the first world war the
fighting that's being portrayed here may
well have happened in the summer of 1918
but for October 1918 it's gone the
French and the British they roll 100
miles in the last three months of the
war this is a really really mobile
fighting but it's just not represented
here so I'd give this at most a 5 out of
10.
[Music]
thank you
so here what we see is Manfred from
Richthofen the famous Red Baron the
number one scoring fight race of the
first world war he shot down 80 enemy
airplanes and he's leading his jagrid
eins so his his flight Wing Fighter Wing
one and he was known as the Red Baron
because he painted his aircraft red this
is his uh I think his final aircraft a
if I could try playing the most
famous aircraft he flew they did paint
their their aircraft in these amazing
bright colors the Germans had these
wonderful Reds and yellows and patterns
there wasn't any tactical reason for it
it wasn't really about recognizing other
Pilots some people say that Richthofen
painted his aircraft red to scare the
enemy but really these German Pilots did
it because they could they liked it so
they did it
thank you
because it does give a sense of the
sheer chaos in 1918 a quarter of the
German air force of German fighter
pilots are shot down and killed that's
how that's how lethal this type of
combat was
[Applause]
you would see scenes like this in the
second world war particularly in and
around I guess above big cities
with unmanned lighter than air balloons
which is called barrage balloons and
their purpose was to force enemy bombers
to fly higher because otherwise they'd
clip their wings and get knocked out of
the air by the wires connecting these
balloons to the ground you do get
barrage balloons in the first world war
but there's not so much use of them you
wouldn't have them strung along the
western front like this so what you'd
see on the Western Front would be
observation balloons the purpose was to
see over no man's land into enemy line
they had baskets underneath them you'd
have an observer
with binoculars
and around the tether connecting the
balloon to the ground there would also
be a telephone cable and they were
really really important in making sure
that that fire the artillery fire was
accurate so it was really really
important to knock them down the thing
is is that you'd only have two or three
per sector
taking down these balloons sounds like
it should be pretty easy because they're
full of Highly flammable hydrogen but
actually it was really difficult and it
was really really dangerous if you fired
a machine gun into one of these balloons
it would pierce the balloon but the
material was pretty tough and what you
would get is simply tiny machine gun
bullet holes which a little bit of gas
would seep out of but not enough to
bring the balloon down in any way and it
was very very dangerous to do because
around these balloons on the ground were
anti-aircraft weapons and first world
war planes are vulnerable they don't
have self-sealing fuel tanks so if fuel
tanks get hits you've got petrol coming
out they're made of canvas and wood it
doesn't take a huge amount to bring them
down with these anti-aircraft batteries
directly below the balloons most Pilots
would steer clear of them very very
dangerous job taking them down
what this pilot is doing is firing a
flare at the balloon the signal flare
which then lights the gas coming out of
the machine gun bullet holes now I'm
really doubtful that that actually would
have worked it's kind of a nice idea but
flares are signaling and I think most
likely what would have happened is that
if you fired a flare at one of these
balloons it simply would have bounced
off it's a bit of a mix there but I was
pleased that at least they showed that
these balloons aren't easy to take down
I give this a five
they're around 85 000 Indian troops who
served on the Western Front during the
first world war and they often get
ignored so it's nice to see that
recognized here the British Indian
army sent over an expeditionary Force to
the Western Front so in order to
increase their land power the British
called over parts of of the Indian
forces under their command Indian troops
served on the Western Front actually
right through to 1918 but the bulk of
them in the Infantry were fighting on
the Western Front in 1914 and 1915. and
this this shows an action by the Lahore
division which had Sikh troops in it in
1915.
nice detail here too this is a subodar
major every Battalion of Indian troops
had one he was the highest ranking
Indian soldier in the uh in an Indian
Battalion and these guys are very well
respected soldiers they would have been
long service soldiers in their 40s or in
their 50s and you can see him leading
the soldiers on just just as would have
happened
you have this aerial attack which
appears to come from behind them which
in itself is odd by an aircraft which
are dropping bombs now there were Ground
attack aircraft but not this early in
1915. there were aircraft which dropped
bombs Behind Enemy Lines on things like
Rail stations and
targets of military significance but
this idea that you had biplanes swooping
down at very low level and attacking
round troops it just didn't happen in
1915 not least because these aircraft
are very very vulnerable they're very
very vulnerable to machine gun fire
rifle fire they're not moving that
quickly and they're not armored so
airplanes kept pretty high up in 1915
this just simply wouldn't have happened
the Germans seem to be firing British
Weaponry there's a Lewis gonna British
light machine gun that they're firing
and they the germs did use looted Lewis
machine guns but not in 1915 the Lewis
machine gun still wasn't on the front at
the time this is going on the mortar I
think is is probably second world war
post second world war no one really
knows even they don't know what's
happening
oh and then the trench as well is is is
rubbish you know where's the parapet and
where's the parados as well this is only
going to bother someone like me I
appreciate that but it's it's it's it's
it's it's nonetheless this is this is
not a good trench it's great to see
Indian troops represented but they could
have actually represented what these men
went through this is just fantasy this
is a one
this clip portrays the morning of the
25th of April 1915 when Australian
troops stormed ashore on what later
became called Anzac Beach at Gallipoli
fighting fighting the Turks against
small against small banded Defenders not
quite as small as shown in this film
there are about 90 of them they've got
the landscape rights it was only a small
Beach these Australians ended up on and
it was surrounded by high hills with
steep slopes and cliffs
[Music]
Turks only start firing once the
Australian soldiers
get off the boats why would you do that
the Australians are in boats they've got
nowhere to go they can't they haven't
got any cover if they dive into the
water they're carrying heavy packs they
are going to drown and they can't do
anything to you at all so if you're a
Defender and you're you're facing an
armada you start shooting before anyone
gets out of the boat in reality the
Turks started shooting of course when
the boats came in Rifle Range
[Applause]
thank you the other big mistake are
these machine guns in the bowels of
these landing craft you're going to hit
your own people clearly you're going to
hit your own people everyone is going to
die and it's not going to be the Turks
who kill them
one thing about this scene as well is
that uh
it exaggerates the bloodness of the
landing there are about 50 casualties on
either side it wasn't as bloody as is
being presented here so
a three
my favorite representation of the war
would be Journey's End not so much for
any realism of of battle scenes in some
ways that's actually less important but
just for how it's so realistically
represents
tension and the claustrophobia of
waiting for an attack in the first world
war thanks so much for watching if you
want to see more videos in this series
click on the link above